donc notre entreprise n'existe pas
depuis plus de 130 ans
nous sommes déjà dans le domaine du textile
été sur le chemin qui signifie commencé
étaient courts dans le cas des pelotes de tissu
puis nous nous sommes rencontrés pour la première fois
vêtu de prêt-à-porter
et maintenant nous marchons et sa troisième fois
et que dans le domaine de la batterie et
l'épicerie donc nous mourons aussi
130 prochaines années de chance de survie
en tant qu'homme d'affaires, vous essayez toujours
optimiser ses produits en
nature économique donc nous avons
fait une analyse de marché et
remarqué le papier toilette avec ça
principal produit d'une crise ou d'une pandémie
est en Allemagne et nous avons donc
décidé ces produits le
particulièrement en forte demande pendant une pandémie
sont d'offrir un soutien afin que les
les clients sont bien pris en charge
[La musique]
[Applaudissements]